best case scenario for the teams that
finished in last place in the four afc
divisions we're going to flip it over to
the nfc today chris
best case scenario for the four teams
that finished in last place in the af
and the nfc east nfc north nfc south and
nfc west respectively let's start with
the nfc east your new big blue big blue
these are not your daddy's new york
giants that's for damn sure 5 and 11
last year what's the best case scenario
for that team
i think first off i'm gonna say this i
think the giants are gonna surprise some
people this year i really do i think
they're gonna be a pain in the butt for
a lot of people in football and you've
heard me say this mike the biggest thing
with them that i first look at always
with any team is offense and defensive
line that's where games can really be
become even or truly unbalanced when one
team is overpowered in a certain area
the giants o line lot better and shermer
is an xo line guy himself i mean so i
look at that their d-line has tremendous
size now a lot is going to be about eli
and who's going to make enough passing
plays in the in the past game i still
think there's enough weapons there to be
had too they're a little unproven in the
secondary that scares me so what i guess
i'm getting down to is best case
scenario okay i don't even think the
best case scenario is play off football
i'm gonna say it's like best case
scenarios just missing out and going
like nine and seven or eight and eight i
think that's the best case scenario and
really i don't think the floor is that
bad either i think the floor for the
giants is like okay maybe six and ten
which i know sounds bad but six and ten
and competitiveness and games where they
lost you know down the stretch and lost
some close ones and i actually think not
making it to the playoffs is best case
scenario in more ways than one because
if eli manning starts all year and they
make the playoffs what the hell do you
do next year yeah what do you do his
contract's expiring do you do a one-year
band-aid with eli manning do you make
him the starter next year do you deal
with this eli manning daniel jones
nonsense for another year now and
because we've heard them talk about the
kc model which would be yeah one year of
eli manning and then daniel jones we've
heard them mention the green bay model
right which was three years of brett
favre before it became aaron rodgers i
think
right and i agree and i agree but
they've mentioned that i mentioned the
possibility of him sitting on the bench
for multiple years right if they make
the playoffs with eli manning as the
starter daniel jones is going to sit on
the bench into 2020 and if he's the
sixth overall pick in the draft at some
point you got to go with him so i agree
with you the best case scenario in more
ways than one would be seven and nine
eight and eight on the fringes of
playoff contention maybe not eliminated
until christmas something like that
where they can feel proud of what
they've done but they can take the baton
out of eli manning's hand give it to
daniel jones say you're our guy next
year and look so much of what they do
this year depends upon how much they
embrace saquon barkley i think it took
them a while last year to really
appreciate that he's your offense not
eli manning right run the ball with
saquon barkley throw the ball to saquon
barkley make him the focal point of
everything you do and then let your
passing game to the outside receivers
develop
around all of the attention that's going
to be clogged up the middle to try to
stop saquon bar yeah he is i mean saquon
barkley's the best running back in
football uh that's all there is to it he
is phenomenal you i've never seen a guy
make you know
more four and five yard runs when i go
there is nothing there to be had or he
gets 10 yards you know i mean how many
times did we see games last year like
troy aikman on that thursday night game
against the eagles he's like that might
have been the greatest six yard run i've
ever seen in my life that might be the
greatest nine yard run i've ever seen in
my life that's what kind of player is he
is generational he is you know it's like
he's the best running back i've seen
since adrian peterson come out i'm
pumped to watch him play this year and
they also need to showcase him to the
extent that sam darnold continues to
develop into a franchise quarterback
because that's the guy they left on the
board and they took saquon barkley and
again if you take a running back second
overall you better be ready to use him
till the wheels come off because
otherwise there's somebody else you
should have taken with that second
overall pick so he is a generational
talent we we hear that term a lot but he
is he is this is true this is real the
question is will he play long enough
will he want to play long enough will he
be healthy long enough this guy's got
hall of fame written all over after only
one year right but i think he can help
them get to
500 in the range of 500 and if they are
any better than that then they're stuck
with eli manning for another year and i
think they don't want that all right
let's let's move on to the af why keep
saying afc nfc west talk about the nfc
the nfc west and the cardinals actually
used to be in the nfc when i was yeah
when i was growing up me crazy me too
louis cardinals and it drove me crazy
and then for a while once they moved to
phoenix they were still in the nfc
arizona cardinals right they are now and
have been for the last 17 years in the
nfc west the arizona cardinals were 3
and 13 last year what's the best case
scenario for them this year they're on
the right track they're going in the
right direction in a lot of ways i mean
they're rebuilding their football team
but i really think best case i mean
truly best case is like six and ten i
just got too many questions across the
board you know one i don't know if
there's enough weapons on the offense
right now in the pass game and an
offense that we know is going to be the
air raid cliff kingsbury cliff
kingsbury's unproven to me the o-line
even though better it looks like it's
going to be better than last year still
not great defense same thing mike i mean
yes there's chandler jones there i'm
excited for him but just a lot of
unproven commodities and patrick
peterson's not going to be there in the
back end for the first what eight games
six six so you know there's just a lot
of things there that i don't know and if
you're watching on tv you see i mean
they had a deep draft they got a lot of
young talent they're trying to infuse
these guys into the roster a little bit
so i just i i don't see you know
anything flirting with the playoffs i
just see them being a pain in the butt
and kyla murray being in a pain in the
butt but ultimately six and ten is about
as good as i'm gonna give them yeah i
think you're right because of the rams
because of the seahawks because of the
49ers that the 49ers are better and a
lot of people think they will be it's a
zero-sum game for every winner there's a
loser and if there are teams in the nfc
west that are playing at a high level
that's gonna
run downhill onto the arizona cardinals
plus they play the nfc south and the afc
north and those are two divisions that i
wouldn't want any piece of right now in
my uh you know outer division games and
i think look i i don't think you want to
come out of the gates and be eight and
eight nine and seven you wanted to build
a little more slowly for cliff kingsbury
you know and and it's going to yeah i
think anything better than last year's
three and thirteen
is cause for celebration in arizona and
i could see it possibly and i i don't i
mean i look at kyler murray and i say
this guy's been so successful everywhere
he's been he won't allow them to lose 14
games 13 games 15 games something like
that but that's really the wild card
with kyla murray football has come so
easy to him throughout his high school
and college career how he is he going to
deal with his first three-game losing
streak how is he going to deal with a
four interception game if that ever
happens
and uh
it's going to be part of the excitement
of the season and i think this is a team
that would benefit dramatically from
getting off to a great start you know we
see teams that win games early and that
confidence leads to more confidence and
by halloween you're feeling like a much
different team than you were heading
into the season yeah all right let's
slide up to the nfc
south the tampa bay buccaneers were 5
and 11 last year i feel like this
division is more wide open than it's
been i think there's a lot of confusion
as to who the best team is bruce arians
was brought in to try to get the most
out of jameis winston the first overall
pick in the 2015 draft he's on his last
chance by all appearances aries is back
after his second career retirement they
have todd bowles to run the defense
which is a positive byron left which
running the offense what is the best
case scenario for these new look tampa
bay buccaneers i mean this is one of the
i mean i i think you know what do i want
to say just one of those teams that's
really
uh kind of i don't want to say outlier
but just an unknown in the nfc south
where i can see it going a whole lot of
different ways here i mean there's a lot
of positives to look at of course i'm
excited about bruce erin's and the
offense and some of the the talent they
have you know at wide receiver and tight
end and jameis winston when his when he
is good it's been really good the
problem is when it's been bad it's been
really bad and i'm hoping bruce arians
can get that out of them now i certainly
think they're going to be better than
511. i think todd bowles being down
there on defense is going to change that
football team too they are big up front
uh i will say that and you know you get
sue is there yeah no no more jpp that
stinks that they don't have that guy
coming off the edge but it's still a
very big defensive front you got the
devin white who was a top 10 pick at
middle linebacker they got some young
studs as secondary a little unproven so
i'm gonna say best case
is like ten and six and they sneak in
the playoffs i don't think that's what
will happen but i i think that's the
best case right where they catch magic
and they actually sneak into a wild card
game but i ultimately think i look at
them being like a seven and nine eight
and eight temperatures see i don't think
there's a middle ground for them i think
it's either gonna go incredibly well or
it's gonna fall apart so the best case
scenario is a playoff birth i think the
best case scenario for the buccaneers is
winning the division and bruce ahrens
being named coach of the year for the
third time this decade that's the best
case scenario
what they would do in the playoffs who
knows but i think they could win that
division that's their best case and
their worst case is three and 13. right
but it all depends upon
whether it works right out of the gates
and we'll know whether or not this is
working we'll know whether or not bruce
arians has the patience for it we'll
know whether or not jameis winston is is
responding to the teaching from bruce
arians early in the regular season but i
think it could go either way and it
could go very well for the tampa bay
buccaneers all right nfc north last
division to get to in the nfc
lions six and ten best case scenario
well
again this is an unknown team here i
mean daryl bevel taking over at oc okay
patricia second year kind of installing
his defense and that system they have a
lot of big people a lot like you know
new england the detroit lions are not
going to lose battles up front that's
the one thing i look at now i do look at
their playmakers in the past game and go
is there enough there man tj hawkinson's
looked good in the preseason uh
especially last week so that gives me an
encouragement there i mean
i guess what i would say man this is
this is a team that i'm i'm picking to
be last in the nfc north and i look at
them and go oh they really scare me i
don't know what to feel here with them
i'm going to say best case scenario
though is they make some magic happen
and i think they could squeak into the
wild card like that
again i'm not gonna pick that to happen
but i wouldn't be shocked if detroit
caught fire and got a run game uh
carrion johnson looked phenomenal as a
rookie last year and matt stafford
adjusted to the style of play and then
their defense takes to matt patricia who
i think they've built the right pieces
to fit that scheme i'll say that's best
case scenario i think realistically i
think they're like a little like the the
tampa bay buccaneers where it goes seven
to nine eight and eight when all said
and done see and at one point we talked
about how
evenly matched the nfc north is this
year and how many great there's going to
be 12 games in that division that are
going to be great great games
and we came to the conclusion a couple
weeks ago that any of those four teams
can win the division any of those four
teams can end up in fourth place so i
think the lions
they could win the nfc north that's
their best case scenario that they do
take to matt patricia that the culture
change under patricia and gm bob quinn
happens more quickly right having a guy
like mike daniels there who said
publicly
when the packers cut him he made a
beeline for the lions because he wants
to play for matt patricia it's just
getting that culture getting them to buy
in getting them to break from 60 years
of
a negative culture a non-winning culture
and you you develop a lot of bad habits
a lot of bad attitudes and they're in
the process of trying to look at that
d-line though that's the real deal right
there when you look at that group keep
those guys healthy and you know run the
ball stop the run and then everything
else flows man you got a guy who's shown
that he can throw the football matthew
stafford he's been in bubble wrap most
of the preseason but if you can run the
ball and stop the run and you sprinkle
in matthew stafford it could get very
interesting in detroit this year all
right when we return
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports